hey 42 here this video is sponsored by
raycon
more info at the end of the video in
in the farthest corner of the world a
strange branch of christianity was
formed
it was called gloriavale based deep
in the south island of new zealand and
it was about to shut itself off
from the rest of the world gloria vale
was a 500 strong community of devout
worshippers
who followed an oppressive and
fundamentalist interpretation of the
christian belief
and stop me if you've heard this one
before but here's some highlights
women couldn't show any flesh to prevent
male lust
while simultaneously ordered to produce
as many babies as they could
i guess they were using the stalk method
competitive games of all kinds were bans
to prevent anyone developing
pride there were violent unnecessary
beatings for male teachers that went
ignored and unpunished
there were unfair working conditions
that subjected members
to excessive hours of labour there were
forced isolation huts for use as
punishment members had fraudulent bank
accounts opened without their knowledge
children were beaten in the name of
god's love
because well what could symbolize god's
selfless love
more than kicking the holy [ __ ] out of a
child right
members who left were cut off from the
community prevented from contacting
their family
and because most if not all of their
family
were born and raised in glory avail that
meant losing
everyone they knew and loved and finally
there were beatings psychological
control forced marriages as well as
whispers of an even darker side to the
cult
that was beginning to leak out into the
wider world
whispers that told of rape child abuse
and unimaginable cruelty
the cult had been formed by an enigmatic
man with a mysterious past
i know crazy right when does that
ever happen he was named neville cooper
and soon renamed himself
to hopeful christian as you do
he led the cult for more than 40 years
and
please restrain your surprise he was
dogged by allegations of sexual assault
and child abuse
which he eventually served prison time
for he was condemned by an ex-gloriavale
member
as a dirty old man a man of unbridled
lust
lies and absolute power and those were
just the good parts
he eventually died from cancer at the
age of 92.
the apologetics index which spends its
time keeping its eye
on christian cult indeed describes
gloriavale
as a cult stating that theologically
this group is a cult of christianity
as its theology as well as its practices
based on that theology
places it well outside the boundaries of
the christian
faith and whilst the main man from
nazareth went around
banging on about the importance of
selfless love never hurting others and
so on
dangerous cults spawning out of
christianity or any other religion for
that matter
are hardly a new phenomenon plonk a big
ancient holy text in front of people
and sometimes you get gandhi or jesus
other times you get hopeful christian
john africa
jim jones or abu bakr al-baghdadi but we
all know about the dangerous cults
charles manson has had so many books tv
series
and movies made about him it's now
impossible to separate fact
from fiction if we're honest we've heard
enough about these cults
the long and short of it is a
charismatic leader arrives
weird stuff happens some or most of them
get sexually assaulted
almost everyone dies but rather
refreshingly
there is a cult out there that is mostly
non-violent
doesn't revolve around weird sex acts
rape or ritual suicide
yet it is in every way
downright bizarre if you travel into the
ocean
a little further north of new zealand
you'll discover
a truly fascinating place
melanesia an area of oceana stretching
from new guinea island
eastward towards tonga which is home to
probably the strangest island cult
in the world allow me to paint a picture
for you
imagine you come across an island white
sand
green palms crystal clear water and open
cloudless blue sky thinking you've
landed in paradise
you move further inland and you discover
something
you can't quite explain there is a
stretch of lands that
looks like an airstrip only it doesn't
look like any airstrip you've ever seen
and instead of lights illuminating the
way there are random burning fires
there are piers for ships to dock at
only
they look like they've been
reconstructed or built from random
materials by someone
who's never seen a real pier
further down the airstrip you see a
ramshackle control tower
or rather a hut in which sits a native
man
ears clad in a wooden imitation headset
operating wooden poles as if they were
controls
at the end of the airstrip you see a
crowd of men marching in formation
clad in western looking military
uniforms and wielding long sticks as
imitation
rifles their drills and marches are
exact
but everything about them is fake and
unusual
you can't get your head around it
everything in this utterly insane scene
would appear to you
as an imitation of american western
structures
and their military only they're just
that
strange imitations in the most unlikely
place imaginable
seeing this you'd rightly wonder what
the [ __ ]
what is going on is this some kind of
festival
this is a satanic pagan thing is
austrian kutcher about to spring from
the bushes
and tell me i've been punked but
searching the nearby fronds you find no
sign of ashton
nor of satan pagans or even festival
goers
you are left in complete amusement if
not a skit for mtv
who or what could this be
approaching the native man or rather the
air traffic controller
you'd ask what is this place what are
you doing here
to which he replies i'm waiting for jon
from
he's coming back with the cargo to which
you'd reply
who the hell is jon from well to explain
we have to go way back to world war
ii to a very odd moment in history
you see during the u.s campaign against
japan american troops leapfrogged across
the pacific islands as part of their
island hopping strategy to establish
strategically valuable positions on
unguarded small islands
this strategy allowed the u.s to move
its forces towards japan
gain a potent stranglehold on the
pacific
and circumvents the more fortified
japanese positions along the way
makes sense so far right well this
island strategy had an unintended side
effect
indigenous tribes native to the island
were suddenly experiencing
their first contact with the outside
world
in the form of the united states war
machine
in all its mechanized capitalist fueled
glory
enormous crusaders to length of fields
destroyers were fierce and fire
sprouting guns
huge broad-winged bombers descending
from the clouds
uniformed gi's of all races marching in
strict formation
with portable cures for any ailment
advanced unintelligible weaponry that
made men fall dead without touching them
strange new languages and customs and
perhaps most importantly of all precious
cargo
that rained gifts down from the sky
too many civilizations at the time all
of this would have been remarkable
but explainable it was a technologically
advanced military
passing through a regular occurrence
throughout world history
but to these indigenous tribes of
melanesians
this was entirely unexplainable as the
great science fiction author
arthur c clarke put it any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and
that's exactly what these tribes thought
it was
magic it wasn't long before cults began
to emerge
worshipping this ostensibly magical
advanced civilization
and the goods they brought with them
even though some of the islanders had
been exposed to the west before
in the form of the british and
missionaries they'd never experienced
first hand
the wonders of the modern world's
mass-produced goods
and all-powerful technology on one such
island
like tana the awestruck populace began
to blend their previous beliefs and
experiences
such as volcano gods and murdering their
disobedient wives
yes they did that with their reverence
for the western world
its soldiers and their mass-produced
goods
thus the john frum cult began to take
root not understanding where these
foreigners gained access to such
enormous wealth gods and industrial
power
they believed them to be a product of
the spirit world
something beyond the reach of mortal men
perhaps
gifts from a god after all these were
not things
that man could make themselves john frum
was one such god a messianic figure said
to have walked out of the sea
or to have lived inside a volcano who
was destined to return with countless
goods and cargo for the people
in many incarnations he is an american
gi
with the name john frum being a version
of
john from america in another he is none
other than prince philip
duke of edinburgh who met one of the
natives during a commonwealth tour
stop-off in vanuatu in 1947.
rumors spread that prince philip was
indeed the living incarnation of the
divine being
john frum safe to say they don't know
him like we do
when world war ii came to its horrifying
nuclear finale
and the japanese surrendered the
americans packed up
and left leaving amongst the locals
only legends of the men from across the
ocean who had all the goods technology
and power in the known world
and so the john from worshipers which
researchers have called
cargo cults because of their desire for
cargo became cemented in the various
melanesian cultures
and ontana the american flag itself is
now a religious symbol
hoisted onto a flagpole every morning
and worshiped
replica runways airplanes jetties
control towers weaponry and soldiers
were all
created alongside complex rituals
in the hope of bringing john from or
specific western figures like lyndon
johnson
back to the island bearing gifts johnson
in particular was predicted to land on
top of a mountain in papua new guinea
unbelievably he never did at its core
the ideology of cargo cults is that
their ancestral gods gave all the
technologically advanced goods or
cargo to westerners by mistake
and so by reenacting these rituals the
gods
or a divine american figure who is the
physical embodiment of john from
such as prince philip will recognize the
tribe natural right
to have these gods instead and thus
remove them from the hands of the
westerners and dropped them onto their
mock runways just as they fell from the
sky during world war
ii over the years the rituals and
praying continued
but the gods or americans bringing with
them
boats cars motorcycles canned food
medicine and so on never arrived
there was just the long empty stretch of
ocean
and silence the only americans who did
return were either
overweight socks and sandals wearing
tourists or veterans looking to revisit
the islands in which they spent their
youth
so little by little the number of these
cults dwindled
and only the john frum cult remained
with followers praying to and waiting
for a man
none of them have ever seen or spoken to
outside of ritual induced hallucinations
this strange amalgam of primitive
myth-making and culture shock leading to
a belief in things that will never occur
has been lampooned in western culture
famed physicist richard feynman even
tore the sciences to shreds
by calling scientists who performed
experiments that were
science in name only not method cargo
cult scientists
this was a dig at a certain type of
scientist who did everything he
thought would produce a certain desired
result but the result he actually needed
empirical evidence never materialized
because the logic underpinning his
science is faulty
culturally cargo cults make a lot of
sense
indigenous melanesian societies were
typically dominated by
big men who use gifts and wealth to gain
prestige
the more wealth he could give to his
people the more influence he had
and the more power he had the men who
couldn't match this were known as
rubbish men and so when faced with a
foreign or
in many respects alien civilization
with access to endless material wealth
and
goods is it any surprise that many
indigenous melanesian cultures
turned into cargo cults after all
who could be a bigger big man than these
all-powerful americans compared
to the americans the previous big men of
the tribe
amounted to nothing they were like
insects compared to gods
and embarrassment to their people from
there it is a short step
to worship and the false hope that their
ancestral strength
will return one day their belief extends
even into the incorporation of christian
symbols in military activity
crosses are used on grave markers and
believers even stage
complex marches and drills with
imitation firearms made out of sticks
western military insignias and national
symbols painted on their bodies
all for the express purpose of
attracting the cargo
and its herald john from
but it's been a long time since the
americans left the islands during world
war ii
so why do cargo cults still exist today
and their belief persist in such
a connected world one cynical view
is that the cults were set up and
persist
through the power of maligned big men
who are running a scam on the vulnerable
and susceptible population
this theory would hold weight when
compared to the general trends of
cults around the world this theory is
also ramified by the fact that most
cargo cults exist outside of authorities
and developed towns meaning information
contrary
to the cult's teachings is prohibitively
difficult to access another view is that
these cults are a result
of relative deprivation where one
society has far less than another
when confronted with a society that had
access to such enormous wealth and
prosperity
the indigenous people focused on these
goods
particularly cargo which reigned from
the sky as the truest expression of
power
prestige personhood and freedom
perhaps the most compelling reason the
cults exist though
is the sense of community they develop
however strange they may seem to western
eyes the rituals customs and collective
prayer
bring people together in a way which is
greatly satisfying to them
and to human beings as a whole whether
or not john frum
is real he definitely isn't the human
need for connection
is powerful unbinding and if collective
worship helps satiate that need
then the cult will endure this is
something modern analysis has tried to
address
the label cargo cults itself has become
burdened with connotations of primitive
thinking
or backwards-ness as it describes a
group that attempts to manifest
a real and tangible outcome cargo
through illogical means worship and
rituals
in truth the behavior of the indigenous
melanesians is far more in common with
creating developing and renewing deep
cultural and social relationships
between people
especially as they are under threat by a
changing world
when you don't understand why the world
around you is changing in the way it is
with such frightening speed and you
don't have the knowledge or resources to
keep up
what more can one do than pray and hope
when one writer for the smithsonian
asked what john frum did for the people
one individual replied that he helps
them to get their traditional customs
dancing and community back after it had
been taken and deliberately destroyed by
the colonial government
and missionaries some even claimed john
frum told them that this was his
express aim to get them dancing
drinking cover a psychoactive tea drunk
in place of alcohol
and simply being themselves once again
when the same smithsonian writer asked
what it was the worshipers wanted in
return for their prayers
one individual responded that all he
wanted was a 25 horsepower motor for the
village boats
so everyone could catch more fish and
have a better life
and isn't that just wonderfully
endearing and with that
i can only hope that wherever he is jon
from
hears them i'm always listening to
audiobooks on the go and around the
house
and i've always been disappointed by the
wireless earbud offerings on the market
especially the extortionately high
prices that was
until i found raycon i like beautiful
things
and these are beautiful just
look at that raycon earbuds started
about half the price of other premium
wireless earbuds on the market
and they sound just as amazing as the
other top audio brands that i know
i find it really difficult to find
earbuds that fit my ears snugly and stay
in place whilst moving or exercising
but racon earbuds fit like a glove
they're just perfect
i can just pop them in go for a run and
not have to worry about them coming
loose
they're perfect for listening to music
or podcasts for hours
without driving your neighbors crazy
their newest model the everyday e25
earbuds are their best ones yet
with six hours of type seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass
and a more compact design that gives you
a nice noise isolating fit
it also comes in new fun colors
like this lovely red you know what i've
been so
genuinely impressed by these earbuds the
super discreet compact charging case is
a joy to carry around and use
and the overall quality and finish of
everything just feels
really high i recommend you get your
hands on these raycon
earbuds today go to byracon.com forward
slash
40 to get 15 of your order
thanks for watching and thanks to raycon
for sponsoring this video